cet homme est en pleine psychose toxique
les appels relatifs à des troubles de
santé mentale
le service de police de l'agglomération
de longueuil en reçoit une dizaine par
jour
c'est cinq fois plus qu'il ya dix ans je
tenais non-augmentation le travail en
silo là ça peut pas fonctionner le
service de police a donc mis sur pied
une division pour traiter les dossiers
de santé mentale la section enquête et
interventions des personnes vulnérables
travaillent en collaboration avec des
professionnels de la santé et du milieu
communautaire
on recule dans le temps des dinosaures
aura qu'un quand on dit que la police a
donné des billets et puis parfois faut
changer cette perception là que ça soit
de déficiences que ça soit des taux
mental perturbé ou que ce soit des
appels ou ce que ça demande beaucoup
plus une intervention borderlands
psychosocial que policier en 2018
le service de police de laval a fait
1100 intervention auprès de personnes
souffrant d'un trouble mental c'est 36 %
de plus qu'en 2014
pour répondre à ce type d'appels urgence
sociale une division de services de
police composé d'intervenants psycho
sociaux etc
il ya un système de garde 24 7 look est
déjà installé donc un intervenant vrai
tu rejoins 24 heures sur 24
prendre la pelle puis estimer le risque
au téléphone sans vraiment la soutient
et ont pas la même formation que nous on
a en tant que policier et c'est la force
de cette équipe un peu partout au québec
les policiers font de plus en plus face
à des personnes qui souffrent de
troubles mentaux selon des données
obtenues par radio-canada le nombre
d'intervention en santé mentale faibles
modérées ou sérieuse de la sûreté du
québec est passé de 14400 en 2014 à
18700 en 2018
une augmentation dont les causes sont
multiples selon les experts
enfin vous policiers mais d'emblée les
colons les personnes sont sous influence
de stupéfiants donc environ une personne
sur quatre qui va vivre un problème de
santé mentale au courant de sa vie et sa
tante et la deuxième chose je voudrais
que les policiers sont de plus en plus
sensibilisés au phénomène selon ce
spécialiste les corps de police faisant
face à cette problématique aurait
intérêt à
avantage collaborer avec des
intervenants psychosociaux en plus de
l'exemple de laval et de longueuil
il cite celui de la ville de sherbrooke
et de la ville de montréal la sûreté du
québec quant à elle a lancé un projet
pilote en ce sens à val d'or et si les
résultats sont positifs
elle pourrait l'étendre à d'autres
endroits il se marie laurence de l'aîné
radio canada montréal